it seems like there's two groups of
people the people who do it as a hobby
right they're doing it they're
collecting what they like and then
there's kind of the professional
investor how do you now that you've been
collecting for a while and actually
building a business in the space how do
you decipher between those two and kind
of do you try to look at those as
actually one group of just or collectors
or is it pretty separated in the way
that they approach actually buying
pieces yeah I guess the way I would
think about it is you know I I guess
your approach to the art market matters
and certainly obviously determines
returns but it's not necessarily
requirement like if you if you look at
data published by a company called
market price or price is basically
constructed its index on the top 100
artists for the past 20 years and that
index alone just every single painting
created by every time when an artist has
slightly outperformed or probably today
materially outperformed the ESPY over
that period of time so in the art market
in general is just really taken off
probably because our prices are we
believe that there are prices are most
likely correlated to global cultural
wealth creation so if you believe that
well theater getting wealthier that you
tend to believe there are prices are
going up yeah I mean I guess that's
intuitive when you think of it through
that lens right and obviously that that
is definitely happening in the world
it's pretty compelling data on that
front help me understand how does the
legacy art market so before master work
enters the the kind of landscape how do
these pieces of art go from an artist
creating them to actually some sort of
initial purchase and then the secondary
and you know and third-order
transactions that actually make the
market of art yes you use the correct
words as they're tuned to two different
segments the art markets they've got one
of the primary market and that just
recently means
paintings that there's something for
their first time and then the other is
the secondary market which means the
paintings were selling multiple times so
to be an artist is represented by a
gallery you're just mixing painting goes
to galleries socials the first section
collector and then that that painting
gets resole
thereafter particularly as the is the
artist market grows as that artist
becomes more popular we generally we
really invest where it's only focused in
the secondary market today you know
there's there's lots of amazing artists
in primary market there's lots of
important artists that are definitely
investment-grade we haven't focused on
it as much just because there's not as
much data behind it so it's difficult
for our research team to understand
returns but you know that's that's not
even think about the market broadly got
it and is there segments of it in terms
of you know I can go to a local store
and buy a 20 piece of 20 dollar piece of
art and kind of put a frame on and hang
it up and that's nice then there's
obviously the you know 50 hundred
million dollar pieces of art that's a
pretty big Delta there how do you
actually segment kind of the size and
maybe sophistication of the various
pieces or buyers yes so this is an
interesting set if you if you look at
just the top 100 artists the top 100
artists constitutes 62 percent of the
overall art market which is 68 billion
dollars so I'm just thinking about it
you know this from a total probability
perspective on being an artist right
there's I don't know probably billions
of artists that have existed
historically and there's really a very
very very few number of people that wind
up kind of commanding the art market
overall so today when we when we talk
about the 60 billion billion dollar
market we're really talking about
hundreds of artists that are there the
vast majority of that and then I guess
what puts somebody in that top 100 right
is it the value of the individual pieces
of art is it something that is less
quantitative and more kind of the story
behind the art how does that get
determined in today's world is probably
different than historically historically
I would like to think and I think a lot
of you argue would like to think that
value is correlated to what we call
cultural significance the cultural
significance can probably be find by
is that institutions collect artists
that appear and other important
collectors collections artists that that
appear in shows with other report
artists there's different ways to
measure cultural significance but you
know today's one a lot of a lot of
values are just driven by commercial
dynamics that are driven by kind of mega
galleries that have a lot of money the
Mon artists have laid the chattering
awareness and you know the the other
thing that's really interesting about
the asset class I think this is probably
unique to our I haven't thought of other
asset classes that are like this but in
order to lives and creates so much work
right so many paintings and then
eventually the best way and then those
paintings get donated to institutions
over time so it's one of the few asset
classes which declines in terms of
volume or supply and that inherently
dries up returns because of scarcity so
that's a that's a really unique
characteristic about art that I think
isn't totally appreciated by most people
and we see that we see that with a lot
of major artists and if you take an
artist like Jackson Pollock I think
today there's there's something like 23
drip paintings and private collections
most of those paintings are not even one
what anyone would consider a painting
art their feet innings or see paintings
but this will sell for three million
dollars because there's nothing else
left so then that's really that's a
really unique characteristic about to
ask